all right Grace So ideally we can
recognize when we are attacked but let's
say we begin to fall for it let's say
there's a phishing attack and we go we
click really fast because we're all
panicked we type in our password and
we're like oh wait I think I just gave
my password to a shady site what do you
do once you're you're compromised in
some way
it's a great question Sal now this is
really unfortunate we hope this doesn't
happen to folks but if it does
there are a few steps you can take to
help mitigate the Fallout from this kind
of phishing attack you should
immediately tell a trusted adult a
teacher or a parent and let them know
that this happened to you this will also
help them make others aware that if they
are hearing from you on that account
that's been compromised
um that so that other folks don't fall
into the same hands of the scammer this
will also help you take steps to report
the scam if possible so for example if
you're using Gmail there is a report
reporting tool within your email
oftentimes you can get alerts on your
phone if there are phone calls that look
like a scam but there are also ways that
you can report that so definitely work
with a trusted adult if you think that
this has happened to you and then once
you've kind of mitigated The Fallout
from that you can look at Best Practices
to make sure that that password isn't
compromised in other places so you are
going to want to update that password
enroll in two-step verification as we
talked about and make sure that on a
regular basis you're changing your
password so even if this happens to you
and you weren't made aware you can
actually mitigate some of that risk if
you're updating and having strong
passwords on a frequent basis there's
another Nifty tool called security
checkup that can actually help you check
on your passwords for all of your
accounts where you use your email to log
in and that helps you keep track and
make sure that you know your passwords
aren't outdated or um you know worst
case scenario that they haven't been
breached in some kind of data breach or
a phishing attempt
super super useful